[Music]
so
okay
[Music]
so
hi table family it's juanita
hi i am so
excited to be able to bring you the
announcements
this sunday as we found out last week
my internet cannot sustain a live
uh participation in the service so i've
had to pre-record these
um so i'm actually recording this on
saturday but i'm really excited
to be with you and to be able to share
and
um honestly to have you see my face
and let you know that i'm still here i'm
alive
i'm doing well um so
announcements i have two announcements
this evening the first
is about our table meetups we want to
give shout outs
um because we're still having our table
meetups um
and this week i'm going to shout out don
and marissa's group
um they have a wonderful group that
meets on the first and third wednesday
of every week day
of every month sorry they meet at 7 pm
and they are focused on
how to be church and community in an
authentic way
um and i know that they've been going
through rachel held evan's book
searching for sundays
but even if you haven't read the book
don and mercer are the kind of people
that you could just jump right in
to conversations with they're really
easy to talk to so if it's your first
time
please don't let the fact that they are
kind of referencing a book be a
dissuasion for you they would definitely
welcome your participation if you're
interested in more information
i think karen's going to put their email
addresses in the notes so please check
them out
that's donna mercer's group and they
meet on the first and third wednesday
of every month at 7pm all right
and then my second announcement is not
really an announcement and we
uh the leadership at the table wants to
just ask how can we help um
this is a really crazy time
that we live in and we know um a lot of
people have different needs
um whether you need prayer or
stuff from walmart um if you have needs
if there's a way that we can be
a help or service we want to serve and
help you so please don't hesitate to
reach out
we encourage you to reach out um you can
reach out to
bret directly or email info at
thetabletx.org
we we want to connect with you we want
to be a service
so if you have needs please don't um
please don't hold on or let anxiety
or shame or whatever it is hold you back
from
reaching out we want to be this is what
we're here for this is what the church
is called to do so let us be church for
you
okay all right well
i normally we do a prayer to transition
into the service but it felt really
awkward
trying to pray for a service
that is happening tomorrow online so
um i actually want to share just a part
of
isaiah 35. um i've been reading
isaiah recently because um
the book of isaiah is written well
several books of isaiah written we're
spending the period of time where
uh israel and the people of god are in
turmoil it is the destruction of the
temple
and exile their entire way of life
was decimated and i found that really
relatable
and there was no sign
there were no signs of
redemption honestly you know
everything they knew was gone and
um in their homes their land
their place and of identity
um was ruined and
so they had to figure out how to hold on
how to continue being a people um
when everything was turned upside down
and so these prophecies in isaiah that
are about
a promise of a return are really
powerful because it's a promise
that was made when there was no sign of
hope
and i think it feels like that right now
it feels like
i have this sense that things
good things are going to come from this
but there's not a whole lot
happening that tells me that and so
reading these words um
it helps me connect to my faith in a
really concrete way
we participate in a very old tradition
and part of our tradition is
resurrection and
and hope even in the midst
of pretty hopeless or devastating
situations
um so i'm just going to read this and i
hope
there's that word again and it is my
prayer
that you hear it as
as something to be planted
um that you water
let you sit out in the sun and then you
cross your fingers
that something's gonna grow so this is
from isaiah 35
it reads the wilderness and the dry land
shall be glad
the desert shall rejoice and blossom
like the crocus
it shall blossom abundantly and rejoice
with joy and singing
the glory of lebanon shall be given to
it the majesty of carmel and sharon
they shall see the glory of the lord the
majesty of our god
strengthen the weak hands and make firm
the feeble knees
say to those who are of a fearful heart
be strong
do not fear here is your god he will
come with vengeance
with terrible recompense he will come
and save you
amen
[Music]
pain i wonder if i'll
ever find my way
i wonder if my life will
really change
all this earth
good all that is
[Music]
all
you make beautiful ways you
make beautiful things out of
[Music]
us
oh
[Music]
is
beautiful things you make beautiful
things
you make beautiful things
[Applause]
you make beautiful dreams out of
[Music]
us
[Applause]
[Music]
make me know you
are making me new
you make me
[Music]
me
you make me know
you are making me
[Music]
me
[Applause]
you make beautiful things out of
[Music]
us
you make me new
you are making
me new making me
you make
[Music]
you are making
me new
this is a poem called force suffering
by an irish poet named john
o'donoghue from his book to bless
the space between us a book of blessings
[Music]
may you be blessed in the holy names
of those who without knowing it help to
carry
enlighten your pain
may you know serenity when you are
called to enter the house of suffering
may a window of light always surprise
you
may you be granted the wisdom to avoid
false resistance and when suffering
knocks
on the door of your life may you glimpse
its eventual gifts may you be able to
receive
the fruits of suffering
may memory bless you and protect you
with the hard earned light of past
travail to remind you
that you have survived before
and though the darkness is now deep you
will soon
see approaching light
may the grace of time heal your wounds
may you know that though the storm may
rage
not a hair of your head will be harmed
[Music]
pull the old chisels
idols of stone that have crumbled like
sandy the waves
i've recklessly built on my dreams in
the sand
just to watch them all wash away
through another day another
trial another chance to reconcile
to one who sees past all
i see and
leeching out my weary hand i pray
that you would understand you're the
only one
who's faithful to me
all the pennies i've wasted in
my wishing well i have thrown
like stones to the sea
i have cast my laws dropped my guards
searched aimlessly
for a faith to be faithful to me
but through another day another
trial another chance to reconcile
to one who sees past old
i see and
reaching out my weary hand i pray
that you would understand you're the
only one
who's faithful to me
through another day another trial
another chance to reconcile
to one who sees pastel i
see and reaching out
my weary hand i pray that
you would understand you're the only one
who's faithful to me
you're the only one
who's faithful to me father we give you
this moment
and all that it carries in it god every
paradox
every mixture of emotion
the good the bad
the gift the hard
god we ask that you would help us find
our way
into honesty in this moment
that we could come before you in all
that we are
and allow you to be everything that you
are god
yeah help us to make room in our hearts
in our minds
for all that you have for us god that
which is beyond our
understanding and that which we have
tasted and seen before god
that we would make space for all of it
that we would accept it receive it
and even bless it
god we trust you as the author the
perfecter
the redeemer the creator
the beginning and the end
we give you this time we give you
ourselves and each other
we place those we love before you
and god we ask you to protect all that
we've committed to you today
it's in your name that we pray jesus
amen amen
amen hey everyone
good evening to all of you grace and
peace
i'm really really glad um that you could
be with us
today and uh i noticed we have some
new folks who joined us um
it was i noticed stephanie acuna and
lorna mcdougall
so welcome it's really wonderful to have
you with us and
a very warm welcome as well to all of
you who
are part of the table community and um
really i want to say particularly to
those of you who have been reaching
out via texts and phone calls
and video chats to one another just to
ensure that everyone feels
like really seen and cared for in this
time i'm want to say a huge thank you to
you that really is
um truly the work of christ right now
and
also a huge thank you to the team uh for
putting on the service today
that was of course uh maggie tilford and
mindy reynolds just singing
and then before them ryan baeron and
juanita johnson doing our opening and
later on closing
and uh and gary miner is kind of behind
the scenes
uh running tech and all that so i'm just
really grateful for this whole team and
the time and energy they put into
helping make
all this possible each week so we are
in part eight of our series
uh titled tranquility cultivating calm
in a crazy world
and i think this this series has been a
timely one in light of just all of the
myriad of changes
in our daily lives that we've all faced
as a result
of the coronavirus and so the title of
my message tonight
is from grief to gratitude
and back again uh i
think we kind of you'll see as we go
tonight that
um i think we're all a little bit all
over the place
you know feeling all sorts of emotions
and maybe in the space of i mean a day
heck maybe an hour we can go from grief
to gratitude and joy and then all
back to grief and you know a little bit
everywhere uh and so
um where i want to actually begin
tonight is with a lengthy
story this is from john chapter 11.
and as i read the story what i want you
to pay really close attention to
is uh the emotions of
jesus so begin john chapter 11 uh
beginning in verse
one now a man named lazarus
was sick he was from bethany the village
of mary and her sister martha
this mary whose brother lazarus now lay
sick was the same one
who poured perfume on the lord and wiped
his feet with her hair that was a
previous story so the sisters sent word
to jesus
lord the one you love is sick
when he heard this jesus said this
sickness will
not end in death no it is for god's
glory
so that god's son may be glorified
through it now jesus loved martha
and her sister ann lazarus so when he
heard that lazarus was sick
he stayed where he was two more days
and then he said to his disciples let us
go back
to judea but rabbi they said
a short while ago the jews there tried
to stone you
and yet you're going back and jesus
answered are there not
12 hours of daylight anyone who walks in
the daytime will not stumble for they
see
by this world's light it is when a
person walks at night
that they stumble for they have no light
after he had said this he went on to
tell them our friend lazarus has
fallen asleep but i'm going there
to wake him up his disciples replied
lord if he sleeps
he will get better jesus had been
speaking of his death
but his disciples thought he meant
natural sleep
so then he told them plainly lazarus is
dead
and for your sake i'm sorry i'm laughing
it's not funny
for your sake i'm glad i was not there
so that you may believe
but let us go to him verse 16 then
thomas also known as didymus
said to the rest of the disciples let us
also go
that we may die with him verse 17.
on his arrival jesus found that lazarus
had already been in the tomb for four
days
now bethany was less than two miles from
jerusalem
and many jews had come to martha and
mary to comfort them in the loss of
their brother
when martha heard that jesus was coming
she went out to meet him
but mary stayed home lord
martha said to jesus if you had been
here my brother
would not have died but i know that even
now
god will give you whatever you ask jesus
said to her
your brother will rise again
martha answered i know he will rise
again in the resurrection
at the last day jesus said to her i
am the resurrection in the life the one
who believes in me will live even though
they die
and whoever lives by believing in me
will never die do you believe this
yes lord she replied i believe you are
the messiah
the son of god who is to come into the
world after she had said this she went
back and called her sister mary aside
the teacher is here she said and is
asking for you
when mary heard this she got up quickly
and went to him
now jesus had not yet entered the
village but was still at the place where
martha had met him
when the jews who had been with mary in
the house comforting her noticed how
quickly she got
up and went out they followed her
supposing she was going to the tomb
to mourn there when mary reached the
place where jesus was and saw him
she fell at his feet and said lord if
you had been here my brother would not
have died
when jesus saw her weeping and the jews
who had
come along with her also weeping he was
deeply moved in spirit and troubled
where have you laid him he asked
come and see lord they replied
jesus wept
and the jews said see how he loved him
but some of them said could not he who
opened the eyes of the blind man have
kept this man from dying but
jesus once more deeply moved came to the
tomb
it was a cave with a stone laid across
the entrance
take away the stone he said
but lord said martha
the sister of the dead man by this time
there is a bad odor for he's been there
four days
then jesus said did i not tell you that
if you believe you will see the glory of
god and so they took away the stone
then jesus looked up and said father i
thank you
that you have heard me i know that you
always hear me but i said this for the
benefit of the people standing here
that they may believe that you sent me
and when he had said this jesus called
in a loud voice lazarus
come out and the dead man
came out his hands and feet wrapped with
strips
of linen and a cloth around
his face will you pray with me
lord jesus we
ask that tonight god that we
would hear your word a word of
a faith a word
of feeling a word of truth
god so give us ears to hear that eyes to
see
hearts that are open to it lord in feet
that are quick to respond in obedience
in the name of jesus i pray amen
so here's the question i've been
pondering
why did jesus cry
you ever thought about that like the
story makes it pretty clear
that he understood that lazarus was
going to be raised and yet
he wept now the story does make it clear
that that jesus wept because he was
deeply moved in
spirit and troubled and
and why was he deeply moved in spirit
and troubled well because he saw
mary weeping uh martha weeping and then
their friends
weeping and it moved him it touched
something deep within him his capacity
for empathy for feeling even for
grief was profoundly deep and in a
similar way
i imagine that a short time later as
lazarus dramatically i mean that moment
i can't imagine that moment
as he he exits the tomb
uh i'm guessing that jesus probably
smiled perhaps
even laughed because he also had a
commitment
a tremendous capacity for joy as well
and this is kind of what i'm getting at
that when we talk
in this whole series we've been talking
about developing a
a christ-like tranquility
uh that this is not the same thing
as a sort of stoic set your
jaw and be unmoved
and indifferent to your emotions
and the emotions of others oh sure
they'll get all worked up
but you don't go there because you know
you're tranquil
no no instead a christ-like tranquility
is about developing the capacity
to be emotionally fluid
when i think of that phrase emotionally
fluid i think of like a dancer
who can go from from one move into the
next
into the next right and it's like it's
like water
you know there it's smooth um
another kind of meaning of this or a
verse that gets at this is romans 12 15
which says
weep with those who weep mourn with
those
uh who mourn rejoice with those who
rejoice
right in other words it's it's not about
um
like being unfeeling uh so much as it is
a capacity to
feel deeply without getting stuck
so it was uh jesus who in another moment
he
he uh brought a little child before the
the wise you know and very grown-up
disciples
and he he placed uh this child
in front of them and he said if you want
to enter the kingdom of god the
the reality of god in the world then you
must become like this little fella
and what's so genius about this antidote
is that jesus doesn't uh like he doesn't
explain it
he doesn't say like okay now what i
mean is instead he just sort of leaves
it
open-ended and we're all left wondering
what what is it about a child
that that we must learn or you might say
re-learn to to be
that moment i think it's sort of like a
good painting or a poem
where every time you return to it you
gain something new from it that's what
the story of the young child is like for
me
because i keep returning to it and
pondering what did he mean and as i
re-read that story uh in light of our
topic
tonight it occurred to me that one thing
that kids are
really good at that adults we sort of
seem to lose it
is that emotional fluidity
in other words it seems maybe that that
with our adult capacity
for emotional regulation or control
that that what if we sometimes end up
losing the capacity for emotional
fluidity
like think about a kid in the space of
one hour they weep for their broken
toy and then they belly laugh to the
point of tears over like a cartoon
character's silliness
and then they become absolutely
infuriated at their sibling over like
stealing their food
especially if it was a sweet and then
later in the afternoon they're playing
with that same sibling
with absolute pure joy and you you get
the sense that they're experiencing it's
almost like they're experiencing the
emotions
so thoroughly that it it just
it just enters into them and just like
flows
through them like water
uh there are are two people
of two adults that i think really embody
this
child like and i'll just go ahead and
call it christ-like
capacity for feeling and i've actually
spoken about them
in uh in a sermon just a few months ago
so i won't dwell too long on them
but uh it's desmond tutu the former
bishop of the anglican church in south
africa
and the dalai lama uh who is the
spiritual and political leader of the
exiled
uh people of tibet and these two men
they happen if you know anything about
them
they're you know they happen to be very
close friends
uh which i think is a beautiful picture
of inter-religious dialogue and
relationship
the dalai lama of course is buddhist um
desmond tutu is christian
um but they've also hosted a series of
conversations like on all sorts of
topics including the topic of joy
and um but as you watch if you ever get
a chance to
to see them one of the best things about
interacting and watching them
is this fluidity of emotion
uh and it's interesting because they're
you know like they're getting older
they're i mean by the time they really
even became kind of in the public sphere
like really well known at least among uh
for desmond tutu i mean they were
it's like into his 50s you know and 60s
and now they're probably
gosh maybe 70s and 80s uh
anytime i bring up age someone's always
like well that's not old but i'm sorry
you know it's all relative it's all
relative
uh but here's what's fascinating right
in the same lecture
both of them they will laugh and then
they'll cry
and then they'll laugh again and then
cry again and i mean i'm not saying like
they start laughing so hard that they're
crying i mean they're like legitimately
sad
and then joyful and then they're serious
and then happy
uh in fact you can actually go online
and like go to youtube and search
desmond tutu laughing or the dalai lama
laughing or the opposite
crying and you can find these videos
like compilations
where they are expressing these deep
emotions and this is
really i mean this is a characteristic i
don't think we often
associate uh with holiness
with spiritual depth with maturity but
but i believe it's
it's really really true uh think of it
kind of like the difference
between a river that flows kind of
quietly
and um without any interruption
verse one that um has a dam
and you know what i'm saying is that
emotion it's sort of like a river
whose water should not be dammed up
uh and so i've been kind of asking the
question or tonight i'm asking the
question
how how do we put up those walls like
what does that look like to
to kind of build those walls that that
unblock that emotion i think it's by
saying things to ourselves
like i should not be feeling
this have you found yourself in that
place in the last few weeks
like i should i should not be feeling
this this this is stupid or
i'm being ridiculous you know i'm a
grown-up
i don't i don't want to feel this or or
i'm done
i'm done with this i'm these feelings
should not be
so have you ever talked to your feelings
like that
maybe not out loud but kind of in your
head um i have
and right when we do this up goes the
wall
and then what happens we find ourselves
stuck so this kind of begs
you know the question like what's the
what's the answer
i think that instead we
must um learn to
not build these walls but we must learn
somehow to say yes
to it to to what is into the those
emotions we must learn
um even to see god in it
like i think back to jesus uh weeping
there and he's what's he doing it's like
he's just
he's just so deeply in the moment and
present to himself and the people around
him that even though he knows in like
five minutes
he's gonna raise the man from the dead
still he's so
deeply and profoundly there
that he cries and then five minutes
later laughs uh and i think
this is the perspective shift we need
like
that we learn um to be so
deeply human and honest that we learn to
experience
god in the midst of whatever we're
feeling
like could it be that god is deepening
us through these experiences and could
it be that the best way to handle them
these strong emotions emotions is not to
to wall them up like a damn or or even
fight them um but to
allow them to be and
even um accept them and you might even
say
welcome them there's uh there's a story
and i cannot for the life of me remember
where i heard this it was some public
figure i think it might have been
richard rohr the catholic theologian
telling a story about his childhood
but he he described uh how
as a child he had a native american
i think it was a neighbor and he said he
was often
mesmerized by um
a practice that she would engage each
morning
so she would rise before dawn
and she would stand on her porch
and the poor the porch kind of faced uh
east
and then in the darkness
she would go like this with her hands
just just kind of rotating them out
and then what would happen right you
know of course what happens in the
morning
in the east like slowly but surely
the sun would rise
she would just stand there
welcoming the light
almost willing it to be
and i think um if i could just like take
a snapshot of
that i i think that's a just a perfect
picture of like the posture um
that we want to uh grow into
with our emotions it's this it's this
posture
of um welcome of kindness
to whatever we and others
are feeling where we let it be
where we um we let it flow right
right through right into and through and
uh and then whether it's a minute or a
week or a month
it's gone and
um you know i know right now
many of you are probably experiencing
all sorts of intense emotions
um maybe you're feeling overwhelmed by
loneliness
perhaps you're you're just angry
uh maybe you're just sad
and if that's you if you're in that
place then what i want to close with is
by giving you
a practice that i think you you might
find helpful
in this season it's called welcoming
prayer and the idea is that whenever
you're experiencing some sort of just
very intense
uh emotion that you take just a little
space
to get alone and then you do these three
steps first you focus
in in this step what you're doing is
you're you're kind of feeling
and you're you're um sinking into
those emotions those thoughts those
sensations those
um kind of commentaries in like your
body you know so if it's an ache in your
belly then you feel bad
if it's a rapidly beating heart then you
feel that
i mean whatever it is you're feeling you
just kind of go there if it's a runaway
freight train of thoughts
then you observe them right so there's a
sense of focus uh
next is you um you welcome them this is
back to that image of the woman
um you're welcoming the holy spirit
into the feelings into the emotions the
thoughts the commentaries the sensations
in your body and you're in this moment
what you're doing is you're you're
acknowledging
that you're not alone with them
right you're not alone in this christ is
with you christ
is present to you he can help you carry
uh whatever it is that you're
experiencing
and then third you start to
um let go that that one by one
you you can start because sometimes
there's an inner kind of attention like
where we're kind of
almost clinging to each sensation and
emotion
uh and and now you can kind of just in
welcoming it notice the kind of the
hands are open
you know so it's not this you know but
it's the sense of
um of just of kind of release
you know allow it to to be there and
then allow it
to pass through you and
um this is something as as i've
practiced this before uh that i've just
found so incredibly um just really
helpful
in this season because it's
it's just so easy to get into a kind of
a confrontational
relationship with our emotions you know
almost an argument
and so i think welcoming prayer is this
a beautiful way of
bringing god uh we're not even bringing
but acknowledging god in the midst of
what we're feeling
and then learning to have a kind of
gentle
thoughtful relationship um to those
emotions
um but also a little bit of objectivity
a little bit of space
you know where we realize i am
i am more than what i'm feeling
that there's a bigger reality to who god
is to who i
am and these things i'm experiencing it
feels like forever
uh but it's not it's not
uh so in closing i want to go ahead if
you'll bow your heads and close your
eyes i want
to um speak this it's kind of just a
blessing
um over you all
so friends of the table my heart
is that in this season when your life
has been turned upside down that you
will be
able to experience it all make
room for it all hold it all
and that when it's time to grieve then
you can grieve
and when it's time to be grateful and
experience
joy then go there and celebrate it
laugh and smile and don't feel
like it's a contradiction don't
feel like you have to choose either
or you're a human being
with a god-given remarkable capacity
for feeling so embrace it
and may we all become like a little
child
child little little children um
again uh so we are
gonna go ahead and uh engage a video
that really beautifully i think just
expresses kind of
all um that we're feeling in this season
so i hope you enjoy
[Music]
do
close your eyes with
[Music]
the pain is rising
feel the weight lay
on your
[Music]
worth having
with the time we have
i give thanks for the time
[Music]
in your breath i feel
how it is it always
ends but give
my god so choose
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i give thanks for the time
thank you all for joining us this
evening
well on sunday evening it's saturday
where i'm really
at right now um i hope that
the message um
was a bomb for your soul or that you
learned something or that there's
something in it that was practical that
you can take into your week
um i want to encourage you like i said
earlier if you have need of something
anything um please reach out to brett or
email us at infotabletx.org
right now this is how we can be church
for one another
and it does require a little bit more
vulnerability sometimes
but we want to be there for you so
take that step reach out let us help you
and then i was gonna show you guys my
puppy but he's
currently napping under my chair so i'll
just send you out
with this benediction and i'll post some
pictures later
the lord bless you and keep you the lord
make his face to shine upon you and be
gracious to you
the lord lift up his countenance upon
you and give you peace
blessings you all love you bye
love y'all have a good one bye bye
bye guys we love you thank you
you